[Music]
on today's show we talked to a woman who
wants to know how to tell her story
about her troubled marriage and the
healing that's taking place we talked to
a woman who wants to take the family to
disney world and one kid is not gonna
let that happen and we talked to a woman
who's a trauma nurse with three small
kids and she's exhausted stay tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with a dr
john delony's show
why are we yelling cause i'm excited
dude
the pre-sale for own your pass change
the future this new book is just running
and gunning i'm i can't even tell you
what
man
okay i can tell you we're gonna have two
confessions today confession number one
is
writing a book is the most nervous i've
ever been like professionally because
there's nowhere to hide i told stories
in this book that i've never told
anybody and you put all your thoughts on
how you interpret the research and the
literature and all the stuff
and
i can't even tell you how grateful i am
how many people have stepped up and
bought it
thank you thank you thank you thank you
ramseysolutions.com or johndaloney.com
you can get a copy of this i'm also
super grateful for betterhelp.com they
stepped up a free month of counseling
so you finish this book and think all
right i got some stuff i got to work on
i got some conversations i need to have
i don't know where to go
they stepped up they got behind this
thing and we've got to hand you a phone
number you have a month of free
counseling go talk to somebody super
excited about that
so hey johnny.com check out and grab
this new book and it will be hitting i
think it comes out comes out in april uh
but pre-sale is going on right now and
james
you called me out on this the other day
when we were recording the audiobook and
i
so here's the thing
the wax of the gummy bears
i'm just saying this because i'm an
addict right it's like no man no like
cocaine's good
the wax of the gummy bears helps my
throat when we're just reading for hours
and hours and hours and there's a
section in the book we're talking about
food and what our food systems and our
food choices and all that stuff
and james says isn't it kind of weird
that you're
talking about this while you're
mainlining gummy bears and i thought
james you're super right like
even if it helps my throat i gotta i
gotta take even more ownership of my
body and my mind and all that
and then alex showed up today
so this is confession number two
dude
it is girl scout cookie season and i
have been
man
i bet my glucose is a thousand right now
my blood glucose
these are so good we'll take those off
your hands and bring them in here listen
yeah if you want to print those three
mints put those thin mints in here i'll
hold them for you there's never been a
live fist fight on youtube
there probably has been a million of
them but not in this studio
dude
samoas oh man if you're just listening
to this i'm holding a box of thin mints
that's mostly gone
and
a remaining unopened boxes of samoas but
i've already crushed the oh man
like i i i think i need to call somebody
i've got
i'm gonna go to the callers let's go to
alicia in spearfish south dakota hey
alicia what's up
hey dr john how are you
i'm hey i'm almost in a diabetic coma
after how many thin mints i've eaten
today but i'm doing great how about you
oh i'm good a little nervous they're
super excited to be talking to you today
hey listen
100 chance you're better at this than i
am so you have nothing to be nervous
about i'm nervous so how can i help
what's up
yeah okay so
um i have been married for 10 years and
in 2019
my husband came forward
and admitted to a sexual addiction that
had been going on
our entire
relationship and um through a lot of
intensive therapy and
um
just
a lot of
other counseling we
have an amazing marriage right now we
just
he's my best friend and
my safe person and we've done a lot of
hard work to get there
but
right now
we are
thinking about
getting our story out there more
publicly like through our
church
and
all of our close friends and family know
but we
feel like we should
tell our children
before
this gets out we live in a fairly small
community and we would hate for
them to find out
by someone else
so when
when and how is the best way to go about
telling them our story
sounds like this is a remarkable story
of bravery and honesty and
redemptions that's
you
alicia are incredible um so walk me all
the way to the to the beginning here um
so you all dated for a while i'm
assuming and then you were married for
10 years
i hear a lot of the phrase sexual
addiction
and
it
usually isn't
but sometimes it is
when you say sexual addiction walk me
through what was your husband
experiencing or what was he doing sure
yeah um it started out with pornography
and then
strip clubs then shady massage parlors
and then up to prostitution okay
and was this interfering with your
finances he was sneaking around i mean
this became a
way of life
yes i had no clue
and yeah he spent a fair amount of money
on it
it i did not notice it
just
because it
in the realm of our income it didn't
make a huge
dent but um a few
thousand dollars worth
um
between
that 10-year
well probably a five-year span i would
say
so walk me through he sits down and
unpacks this for you
tell me about that day
um he came forward
to me saying that he was struggling with
a pornography addiction and
again i was blindsided i was really hurt
by that
and after a few days of processing i had
a few questions
about that
and
at the i had about no probably 10
questions to ask him regarding the
pornography and then
at the end i said i know this is a
ridiculous question but i just i have to
know have you ever cheated on me
and i mean we were watching the office
it was a friday night and i was not
expecting the answer that i got
and wow
what a moment to ask a shape-shifter
question right
yes like i said i was not
expecting i was expecting to be
reassured and
it just all came crashing down and
um
unfortunately my oldest daughter at the
time heard me freaking out and
um
my husband tried to like calm her down
and send her back down to her room to go
to bed and
but it was our pastor came over and one
of my best friends came over to
help be with us
in that moment
but yeah it was very true it's a
traumatizing time yeah and so what has
happened over the last couple of years
to
help heal
you your marriage i mean
ten years of of dishonesty and betrayal
is a long time what has happened in the
last two years to have you speaking so
highly of him
well i was
he had been pretty emotionally
disconnected our whole marriage which
makes sense now but um
so when he told me this i was ready to
file for a divorce and you know i
i couldn't get an attorney to call me
back so i
agreed to go to
counseling with him because he really
wanted to
make it work
and so
yes did
like
a few weeks of intensive therapy and a
different state and
and you know he never once
um
blamed me
he took full and complete ownership
and i just saw
so many
tears from him and
he let me
yell and
scream and he just would say i know you
deserve so much better and
he
um just put a lot of things in place
he's been in several accountability
groups and
um
and he actually set up consequences for
himself when he would
if he were to even say a white lie he
would
sleep on the floor at night and or drink
a cup of pureed broccoli because that
was something he wanted to fix in
himself
so he was very determined to sober up
and um
the way he's been with our children has
just been incredible um
so can i ask you can i ask you a a
deeply personal question
sure
um and you may have heard me talk about
this on this show
one of the most common things i hear
from folks who are in a relationship
where there's cheating
is
that the rage and the anger and the
mistrust and all that
but
deeper than that more painful than that
or more maybe not more painful but more
disorienting than that
is that i shared a bed with a guy for 10
years and i missed it i didn't know
and it i
i'm crazy like i feel crazy how in the
world do you miss your husband with
prostitutes and with
you know massage parlor trips and how
did i miss thousands of dollars right
and you start backtracking it it's
almost like uh watching fight club for
the first time and you realize oh i
missed the whole movie all right or the
sixth sense or something right so
how did you feel
or are you just are you good
if you are you you need to bottle that
up and sell it because that's incredible
well
i still struggle with that whenever i
get
a little uncomfortable with
a situation as
he has to go out of town overnight
somewhere
i
yeah i do still
struggle with that but
not it gets so much easier
as more trust is built okay there you go
and he yeah he's just been
very open and honest with
yeah whatever
i need to look at he's
willing to give it to me awesome so he's
he's he's doing his best to live a
transparent life which lets you
breathe a little bit right
yes it's awesome
all right so here's a how old are your
kids
i have a seven
four and nine month old
okay
so tell me about this decision to
be public with this story
what are y'all thinking yeah i
uh my eyes have just been open to how
big of a problem this is and
um
and i've had
friendships who have had struggling
marriages with
um
husbands who have gone outside the
marriage
and
i just
want to be able to provide a sense of
hope that
it can work out if you make it
if you put in the work for it sure
so um
my rule of thumb and this is going to be
different um and again i'm not basing
this on any research that i've read so
let that would be clear this is coming
just from me
my rule of thumb is
is however long a thing went on
is how long you wait until you start
telling that story publicly
and here's here's a couple here's a
couple things to think through
it's generally it's with
folks who struggle with drug abuse or
folks who struggle with financial issues
that the moment they get
clean
for any any period of time
they want to go tell everybody about it
and what i've seen over and over and
over again and this isn't your story so
don't hear me talk about into your story
and i'll give you some context for i
think for your situation specifically
is
you can end up taking people with you
the second time
if you have a relapse if something goes
wrong if something gets off the tracks
and
i want to see people be whole and well
before they start so for me i was
buried with anxiety i was buried with
nonsense i didn't treat people right it
was a decade ago
and now i'm becoming i'm talking about
it publicly now i'm writing books about
it now i'm speaking about it because
i've got a decade's worth of healing
underneath me does that make sense
uh yeah and when the attacks come
when people write me and say you're full
of crap you misinterpreted this research
i think what you're saying is nonsense
and i've had some
prominent people in the country really
challenge me on some stuff we got toe to
toe and on some hard stuff right
and i've had equal support too so it's
not like it's just raining but
if i hadn't had this long of healing if
i wasn't this secure and what i think
and what i know and i didn't spend this
much time in the research and the
literature all that
those things would decimate me and
inadvertently send me right back to
where i was now it may not be a sexual
addiction like in your case
but addiction will find its way out in
other places it may even be and this is
going to sound crazy
addiction to transparency
anything that i'm holding on to as a
crutch to get through a hard season or a
boring season or tiring season
ends up being an addiction that doesn't
mean you guys wait 10 years
okay
here's what i think
you guys can do
we had a
we regularly my wife and i
almost oh my gosh sometimes every week
um this past weekend had a couple from
out of state
working on some stuff working through
some stuff
um came and stayed with us thinking
through some things
that happens all the time and the um the
work that my wife especially she's just
so gifted
but that we do behind closed doors with
people that nobody ever ever knows
that ends up being legacy shifting or
shape-shifting and it's not that we're
doing all the work but we're providing
space and some encouragement and some
wisdom and some walk alongside yep did
that too i've been there too
um
that
it doesn't need to be spoken publicly if
you are a resource and a caring
person caring couple in that way
man you will find yourself inundated
with people who want to talk to you
behind closed doors how your friends
showed up for you in the middle of the
night
you could do that for 10 years and no
one would ever know on instagram that
you're doing this and you are saving
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
marriages
just by your presence just by your
willingness to speak
and eventually that becomes hey i'd like
you to come talk to my group like
whatever i went and spoke to celebrate
recovery group i'm gonna talk to a
church group i'm gonna whatever that is
hey would you come talk to our group or
at work hey we'd love for you to talk
about this but there's a way to lean
into this without
i wish i had another way to do it
without getting famous for it
okay yeah it's so easy to to jump from
the crazy story to we should write a
book
um here's a simple example in my house
my son when he was born my wife was a
um she was a nationally recognized
researcher when it came to child
literacy i'm teaching teachers how to
teach kids how to read she was a savant
and then my little boy comes along and i
have a phd in higher education i spent a
lot of time in student development and
childhood development that's just what i
did that's what she did
our son was incredible
temperament wise
attitude wise he just was a great
easy kid
he was really articulate he could speak
well he could read at a young age
and there came a moment when he was i
don't know four or five i'll never
forget the arrogance what a [ __ ] i was
and i looked at my wife and said
i think every other parent is an idiot
this isn't hard if you are incredible
and brilliant like the two of us
and she probably rolled her eyes but i
didn't pay attention because i was too
arrogant back then and i said we need to
quit our jobs and good on the road and
write a book about how to be a great
parent
and then we had my daughter
same parents
same same geniuses
just a totally different human
and my daughter is incredible and she is
a human hurricane in all the best ways
we have no business writing
writing books on this right now right
and so i tell you that to tell you this
i would slow down you're talking the
healing here is three years two years in
a little bit of time
for a decade or 12 or 15 years of
betrayal
that's still relatively raw
when it comes to talking with your kids
seven four and you know obviously not
the nine month old seven and four
that's real young to sit down and say
hey mom's mommy and daddy are gonna go
talk about all the stuff we did or the
stuff that happened to us and what daddy
did and um
maybe your seven-year-old could have a
context there but it would have to be
very high level very age-appropriate
no seven-year-old is going to understand
massage parlors or
prostitutes or um
they would understand daddy made some
really big mistakes and it hurt mommy a
lot
and now daddy's um
changed and he has really grown hard and
mommy has forgiven him and when y'all do
have that conversation you're holding
hands you're seeing each other you're
smiling
and
because as soon as you talk about that
fracture
that kid's body is gonna go into fight
or flight oh no
right
and
i'd be very very careful and very slow
age-appropriate introducing that stuff
what happens a lot in this situation is
parents want to absolve themselves of
what they're carrying around and the
kids are not strong enough to carry it
so don't tell them because you feel like
we just got to be honest with everybody
bro like they can't handle it it's too
heavy right
as they get older
and
they make you have high school kids now
you're talking you can sit down and have
some harder conversations maybe even
middle school again but we're all
talking very age-appropriate
when i would actually sit down and say
hey son or daughter i gotta talk to you
about some stuff i did when you were
before you were born
um
i mean you're talking
junior senior in high school maybe even
later maybe in college like i got some
stories i got to tell you um here's what
kind of jerk i was and here's how sick i
was for a season
um that makes sense i feel like i'm
bursting your bubble here and i know you
guys have a heart of gold and want to
help other people
um i i what i really want is i want you
all to be wise and i care way more about
your marriage right now
and your three little ones than i do a
story or a book that can be written
does that make sense absolutely yes i
totally respect that and
um i guess i'm it's more about when
to tell the kids who i'm afraid if we
don't
if
like if we wait until they're in high
school or
college age are they going to be really
mad that we kept this from them let me
feel even more
what would it be
no what does it gain them if you lie to
them yes
if one of them ever asks you in middle
school when they get cheated on the
first time
you don't even know what this is like if
this never happened to you has it and
you can say oh honey i got a story to
tell you
right if you lie to your kids that's
where resentment comes from
choosing not to burden your kids with 10
years of infidelity and 10 years of
prostitutes and massage parlors that's
big time when your husband and you sit
down to have the talk about pornography
which i've had both of my kids now six
and 12 right
when y'all have that conversation you
could talk about hey there's some hard
things
uh but there's stuff i'm not talking to
my son about yet
and i'm real real open with him
he's not there yet he's not there yet
and so one day we'll get there one day
we'll have some harder conversations or
some deeper conversations i'll tell them
about some of our friends that he knows
and loves some of our community members
and family members that he knows and
loves
but right now i'm more focused on
telling him the truth
then i am lying to him
does that make sense
absolutely okay in a radically honest
house like you have now
don't let that don't don't
hand your kids bricks of truth if
they're not strong enough to carry it
okay
that's fair easily yeah i can definitely
do that but i don't i don't want to
burden them with
with that if it's not going to help them
can i tell you this
you're a great
mom
like thank you no no you just you gave
me the um which is your way of
dismissing things you're a great mom
you're a great mom
and
there's a season of doubt that's still
here that's normal it's it'll take years
to heal
and you're not crazy
and this guy won the lottery
with you
absolutely won the lottery
and
outside of the the challenges infidelity
the way you talk about him sounds like
you won the lottery with him too
and i definitely did so you all are
going to continue to grow and heal
together and you're going to create
something
masterful that will bless a bunch of
people i want to see you bless people
behind closed doors for a season
quietly through relationship over the
over a kitchen table with meals
nobody ever knows in and out
and get good at that
get honest with that continue your
healing journey with yourself and with
your husband
and man then the book will come one day
the big story and the big reveal that
will happen one day
i would just let that play itself out a
little bit longer we'll be right back on
the dr john dolone show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance i can't get off work and time
to go see somebody it's way across town
what do i do because i want help with my
anxiety my depression my relationships
are hanging on by a thread i want to be
a better mom i gotta process this trauma
that happened to me when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back let's go to casey
in raleigh north carolina what's up
casey
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm doing pretty good um i love your
show so much happy to talk to you today
hoping you can help me a little bit i
don't know about that but thank you for
loving the show that makes me happy
yeah
well so it's gonna start out sounding
very um
uh trivial but we'll get into it a
little bit so we currently have um a
disney trip planned for may
um which we've had to rebook two times
because of covid but
we're really excited
except for i'm also extremely terrified
because of my son my um oldest son
um i'm really nervous that he's going to
kind of ruin our trip um
i know this sounds horrible
not at all but not at all talk to me
about what's going on
um
so
every time that we've taken him on a
trip um you know we go into it with with
really high hopes and good expectations
kind of trying to lay the groundwork
but he
is very controlling and
when he's not in control of situations
he can become
very defiant and kind of downright mean
extremely volatile and just very hard
for him to
regulate his feelings
um how old is he a lot he's almost nine
so he'll be nine um in april of this
year so
um
and i just feel like the whole family is
always kind of walking on eggshells with
him and
like constantly trying to navigate
situations so we don't trigger him and
um you know so
i just constantly feel like i'm trying
to unravel a puzzle of like his heart
and mind and
i don't know how
a lot of times sorry if i'm getting a
little emotional no it's hard yeah and
his sister
who is she just turned six
she is the complete opposite she is so
go with the flow she's easy going but i
also kind of you know
look at her sometimes and
i see her when he goes into this these
you know heightened
deregulated emotional
places that she just kind of kind of
goes into a shell a little bit or
disassociates a little bit and just kind
of like goes into her own little world
where she's almost
very unresponsive
so responsive you know
tell me about your tell me about the i'm
sorry to interrupt you tell me about
tell me about home life
is there chaos at home
i mean
i don't want to say yes but
i mean if it's not say no if it is say
yes
i mean i don't know that it's chaos it's
just busy
there's a we're we're very busy my
husband and i we both work
um quite a bit
you know
we we always have something going on i
wouldn't say it's chaotic it's just
i feel like we're constantly trying to
not discipline him but like
regulate him daily and it's it's
actually kind of put a strain on the
entire family
um so over time what you've described to
me is both with him and with your
daughter
are two
two response systems to the same issue
and
i'll simplify it here but
you've we've got a fight flight or
freeze or fallen response system
when things get chaotic when our bodies
feel out of control
or unsafe
and for a kid a lack of connection is
unsafe
a lack of
really firm boundaries i know where i'm
anchored in here
their body says sound the alarms we're
not safe things aren't okay
a
marriage of two parents who are not on
the same page or who are running a gun
in who are chaotic who have things going
on behind closed doors
that tells a childhood body you are not
safe
and this i must have control this unregu
this dysregulated
um i will get oh i will find a way for
you to see me uh-huh
is a is a biological response it's off
it's rarely a in fact i struggle with
even character issue for an
eight-year-old this is his body taking
over and then you got a daughter who
knows i'm gonna disappear
i'm gonna i'm gonna vanish
saying i mean you're talking about the
freeze response right uh and if you have
a third kid that may nuzzle up to you
and that might be the fond response
that's the way i'm gonna get super close
to my the person who i'm terrified of or
the situation i'm terrified of and i'm
going to love them through this and if
i'm really close and i'm in love then
they won't they won't hurt me i won't be
hurt
it feels something environmental going
on here
um and that's that may be for a
different phone call
but
what i
this is one of the curses i mean i just
wrote a book about this almost this
exact thing there's a couple of chapters
about this very thing which is
we have just kept running faster and
faster and faster
and we've without even meaning to
created a world that our bodies cannot
exist in
and then we bring kids into it
and
man we throw diagnosis at him we throw
uh behavior plans at them we throw
school punishment at them we throw all
kind of stuff at them
and if we distill it way down
their behavior is a language and what
they're telling us is i don't feel safe
my house and it's it's
i mean it is trust me i've been there
too i've been there too
does that ring a bell with you or am i
out to lunch and feel free to say you're
nuts
no i mean it does ring a bell with me
however
you know we have i feel like and and but
maybe it's just because i'm trying to
figure out like you said a diagnosis in
a way because he's like an angel at
school like anyone outside of
our immediate family and maybe my
grandparents and like sister and
sisters
like nobody else would know anything
like this about so what does he get at
school
structure
firm structure very very clear
boundaries
a teacher shows up every single day with
the same routine
yeah there's no race to this and then
we're gonna go to that and then hey
everybody's gotta get up because we all
know we just go when the bell tells us
or we all go it's it's 11 10. we all
stand up we go to the line we stand
there
so school is a highly
structured safe place and i don't say
safe place like in the awoke you know
get in a box so nobody can say mean
things safe
safe physiologically biologically for
his body
and the adults are slow they talk quiet
they look you in the eyes they get down
on your level
you hear what i'm saying it's it's these
tiny behaviors
and i'm telling you this not to guilt
nobody wins with a guilt trip that's
what i'm trying to do here
right it was a shape-shifter moment when
i realized the way i was doing life was
contributing to the chaos of other
people's lives around me
and i wept it was hard i had to grieve
it because i didn't mean to be doing
that i thought i was getting everybody
amped up and we're going we're gonna
we're gonna
we're gonna
man we're gonna slide in to the end of
my life with no tread left on the tires
we're doing it all working at all and i
realized i was uh uh i was like being
married to a taser
everybody right and so i tell you that
that that's a separate question you even
called me
how's your marriage and i'll just be
totally honest
you all good
no okay there you go
and that's that may be a third step
we'll just make you a regular on the
show
right i could use that actually probably
but like i've picked up some of the
things from your show that i've been
trying to do like the physical touch
you know like making sure and and we've
been to a lot of like play therapy and
like relational therapy types of things
to try to like
you know figure this out a little bit
and you know he loves like you know
we'll go to bed before we go to bed at
night we like make a pizza on his back
which is so random but like it calms him
you know it's the touch and then like
the thing that you've said about putting
the hand on the back of the neck and
30-second hug we've really been trying
to do that too but what other ways can
like i mean obviously it's a big
question but like how can we start
making him feel more safe and secure
without just like those quitting our
jobs
tomorrow you know two things
number one
and i'm just putting this out there one
of you may have to take a reduced load
or do something different that might
come to it
first and foremost when somebody calls
me and says hey i need a book about
anxiety for my kid
or what is your recommendation for
childhood anxiety
the first thing i say is fix your
marriage
and not one person has ever come back
when they asked me that question and
said dude my marriage is great that's
perfect why
now i'm not saying that um
there's a one-to-one
causal relationship here the correlation
and my experience is very very high
and so the greatest gift because here's
the thing when you're in a marriage
that's rocky that's messy
that's even
even if it's not rocky or messy
and you're laying in bed at night next
to somebody that you love and you feel
totally alone and i know you know what
i'm talking about right
when you feel that your body becomes
dysregulated
what you have is you've got years of
maturity you've got professional
responsibilities and you've got muscle
that you can gut it out but a kid's body
absorbs every second of that
and so if you've got two adults living
in a house who are co-managers but they
are not they are not intimate and that
both sexually and
psychologically and spiritually if
they're not on the same page the kids
absorb that tension
they absorb it and so when somebody says
hey how do i help my kids got anxiety
the kids really anxious all the time
they're running i always tell fix your
marriage go see somebody today
because your kids are going to anchor
into that and a good marriage at home
there's some great studies on kid
happiness
in third world countries where there's
deep poverty
but parents are connected
and the kids are anchored in so tight
to that thing and then they can swing
down and act like kids and be maniacal
and go through kids stuff and fall and
break their arms and fail and screw up
because man i am tethered into something
really tight
but then you come over here man we got
all the money in the world but we're
we're like i say we're co-managing our
houses we are not in intimate
relationships with our spouses anymore
and the kids are just free falling
and then i i absolutely 1000 know cause
i've been there
how hard this is to hear
i know it
when it comes to the disney world thing
this is a uh she was a shape-shifter
moment for me um sitting down with a
child psychologist child counselor that
i just love and have high high respect
for and she put a lot of time and energy
into mentoring me
um
two important things we number one we
always as a parents we get this picture
in our head
of what a family or our family is
supposed to and or gonna do
and then come hell or high water we make
sure this freaking thing happens
and
the second thing is is we tell our kids
what they're gonna love
i just did this the other day we had a
foot of snow here in nashville and i
told my daughter you are gonna love me
shoving you down one of our hills in a
thing just trust me
she hated every second of it and i
should have listened to her
right now there's those times you need
to push them and say right so that's
what i'm talking about
when i take my my daughter let's say and
say hey we're gonna go to a movie and
ten minutes in
she says
i i i don't feel good can we go
somewhere else
my temptation is to say
no i paid for this movie we're watching
this movie what she's really trying to
tell me in her limited words is i'm
dysregulated this is too much
stimulation i'm overwhelmed i really
like to just go walk around a park with
you
and i should have gone to the park in
the first place i'm the one that was
like no you should do the movie too so i
would tell you
if you can't
if you're a family unit
and that includes all of your kids if
going to disney world doing disneyland
is not gonna be a net benefit don't go
don't go don't don't torture each other
just to say we went to disneyland
or so that y'all can post about it or
tell your friends or it's a status don't
do it if you and your husband want to go
go by yourselves and don't even tell
your kids just go
but there's a picture in your head and
now it's been worse because it's been
canceled twice
stupid
this is i i don't give a crap this
vacation is happening kids we're right
and i get i get that
if your eight-year-old's gonna be
miserable and your daughter's gonna have
fun until she's not
don't go
go camping at a k you know what we did
last for vacation last year we went to a
koa
it cost us like 28
and my kids are still talking about that
vacation and i felt like a sham of a
husband and a dad i felt so lame and now
dude i'm all i'm koa all day i'm gonna
get koat tattooed on my chest it's so
awesome right not really right but yeah
it was so lo-fi so chill and it was
incredible because we did the vacation
that our family needed not the one that
was going to get me acclaim with my
friends and community and that i had in
the back of my head
yeah i mean to be fair they've been
saying they want to go for the past two
years oh what kid doesn't want to go of
course
of course and my kids also tell me that
they would love love love ice cream for
dinner
and they all i also know no you don't
because you wake up tomorrow you feel
terrible
and you're not gonna sleep tonight and
you're gonna be miserable at school and
you're gonna get in trouble and and so
there's part of that parent as parents
in childbirth she was discernment right
but i get that no kid is gonna be like i
don't wanna go to disneyland are you
crazy no no kid will say that but they
will fight and clawed scream and throw
fits and feel unsafe
i would love for y'all to go man i'd
love for my family to go
um we're saving up to go someday i would
love to
um
but man i gotta make sure everybody's
involved
will you heal your marriage or were you
at least leaning into that
yeah i want i want that for you i want
that for your husband i want that for
your whole family squad man you're super
worth it
for real and have you taken him to get
tested your son oh we got lots of them
lots okay and
i hear this all the time you've got all
the diagnosis in the world all the
whatever plans and all that this is and
that's
there's a core issue here my guess is
and again you and i are talking for 10
minutes on the radio my guess is
um on the podcast here my guess is
there's a chaos in the family system
somewhere maybe you just sit down with
your husband tonight and say hey
i talked to this guy i talked to a coach
today
like things feel off the rail like we
are running so fast i miss you
hey what happened we got to own what
happened and
[Music]
man
can we just start telling each other the
truth i'm not okay and we're not okay
and i don't think that you're okay you
all start there
and
so often the kids stuff begins to take
care of itself when mom and dad are
super locked in
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change save yourself the headache and
call churchill mortgage today at triple
eight loan 200. trust me that's triple
eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back and come on eileen
in omaha what's up eileen
not much how are you super good how
about you
i'm all right
uh-oh um what happened yeah
well actually that phone call right
before kind of hit close to home oh
my question to you i guess is kind of
how do i get my marriage and family life
back on track oh man
well
i guess kind of a little bit of
background i'm 26 my husband's 27 we got
married pretty on 21-22 so we're going
on five years here
um i've got three kids we've got one
that just turned four two-year-olds and
a three-month-old
i'm a trauma nurse i work full-time my
husband is a subcontractor has his own
business
and we've kind of been really working
hard the last five years we've paid off
my schooling we've just finished
building our home
um and we have a decent marriage but
things just don't seem to slow down for
us
i feel like we're both just so
exhausted
at all times and we just can't get on
track
yeah i'm so i'm so hard and i hear that
little i heard that little baby in the
background it's all good trust me i got
i got two myself it's all good um you
got you got three small kids or two
i've got three
a four-year-old a two-year-old and a
three-month-old
three oh my gosh okay
so
a couple things number one
you've been married five years did y'all
date for a couple years before that
no it was like from the time we met
to getting engaged to getting married it
was like a year and a half
wow
way to go moving quick i love it
um okay so
you are in what i call the window
five to seven years is a window seven to
ten years is a window
and then that
15 to 18 years is a window
and it's a window where
you
are
running and gunning this is the one
y'all are in running and gunning
you married somebody
then there's a lot of new variables like
jobs and work in school and i don't know
three kids ages four and
under right so you throw all these
things in there and here's what happens
we stop liking who we become
yeah
and that reflects how we that that
impacts how we then
interact with other people most
importantly the person that we love and
committed our life too
and so these are seasons when marriages
start to have cracks in them and people
start to get exhausted and they start to
lean this way and that way right
and it's often people will blame their
partner in this deal
that's usually not it usually
i don't like who i've become i don't
like how i look i don't like how i feel
i don't like i used to be fun and spunky
and i just want to go to bed every night
at 4 45 p.m right
oh yeah all those things right so
tell me about eileen
you sound like an
incredible woman
why are you struggling with eileen
honestly i can't even
figure that out myself i feel like
before i was really energetic
really outgoing i was a people person i
come from a bigger family i'm one of
seven the second of seven and my husband
is one of nine oh so you all just got
started
we come from large families and it just
feels like we're almost like used to
this chaos
in a way but now that we've got work and
we have a farm and we've got the kids
and we both work full time it's like
even things such as date night there's
such a burden
and i've like tried to do the whole
thing you know i've listened to your
show where it's like schedule it on the
calendar and
sometimes i'll do that and we're just
there and i'm like well do you want to
be intimate he's like do you want to be
intimate i'm like no i'm tech me too
let's go to sleep wait the three month
old is up the toddler's back in our room
and yeah it's like
i just feel so burnt out and i don't
even know who i am i put on like 70
pounds with the three kids i started
going to the gym but even going to the
gym it's like i
constantly have all these things i need
to get done
that my mind it just never turns off and
i feel like i'm not being a good mom i'm
not being a good wife i hate i always
loved being a nurse until maybe the last
two years i hate doing that
but i don't know what i like yeah
you know and so i don't
i don't even know i guess who i am
anymore
and my spouse is great he's always you
know if
he's always encouraging me to go out and
to kind of do things for myself and when
i'm just completely burnt out he takes
over when he's really exhausted i try to
you know cover for him but it's just
like we can never be in a good space at
the same time almost
wow thank you for articulating that
you're awesome
um
have you heard me talk about bricks
in the backpack
all right
so
this is an important
moment for me and
me getting well years ago okay
um
you can have trauma as a kid you can be
the big car wreck and we think of the
word trauma you know this you're a
trauma nurse like man
people
i've been in trauma units with some
regularity for a season
it's stunning the things that people
find themselves wound up in right yeah
wow literally wound up at things
sometimes right so we
we know of trauma as the big thing they
got coveted and two weeks later they
were dead they got hit by a car
he was cheating on her for 15 years and
she didn't know and he had another
family we know of big t trauma
and so when i think of trauma we were
all born with a backpack and some of us
were born into families that were the
only african-american family in the
neighborhood that's trump that's hard
right when you look around and see
nobody looks like you
families who are born into abuse family
who's born into
this is just the way we do things the
wrong religion the whatever the thing is
so people are launched into the world
with cinder blocks in their backpack
some of us have none some of us have
several
and over time in our life
they we we collect these bricks over
time
and then i ran into my friend
um dr lynn jennings she is a
she researches secondary traumatic
stress
and i didn't know what that was
and
the the there's a whole backstory to it
it's an extraordinary thing and it gave
me so much insight into my own
physiology my own body
when you live and work and walk
alongside people who are hurting for
your job when you go into the fire
to help others
it's vicarious trauma it weighs on you
too and it might not be a cinder block
but it might be pebbles or it might be
medium-sized or tennis ball sized rocks
that go in your backpack day after day
patient after patient
moment after moment hard conversation
with family after hard conversation with
another family
and over time in short order if you're a
trauma nurse that weight in your
backpack is the exact same of somebody
who grew up in a big time traumatized
household
and you're carrying that around and then
you've got so just picture yourself with
this huge backpack full of rocks because
every day you're putting in
um
you're taking care of people right
you're intubating people you're jabbing
them with all kinds of whatever things
you're putting in their arms and bags
whatever you're doing there's a trauma
nurse right sewing people up holding
people together right
and then you walk out with this backpack
full of bricks on and you're like well i
gotta go be sexy tonight that ain't
happening
and by the way i got a three month old
that my body is still a
uh
a machine slash jungle gym and yeah i
got to get done with that with i got to
get done with work so that this guy can
then get all hands right i mean
at some point what you have to do is you
got to deal with the trauma
whether it's secondary trauma whether
it's real trauma whether it's a
combination of both most of us have a
combination of both
and
i can't tell you
how hope you can hear my voice
how
lighter i walk through my life now that
i got came up with like i got a system
for dealing with these secondary trauma
that i got a system for dealing with the
big bricks
and i got a system for dealing with them
when they show up time after time
and some of that's meeting with the
counselor some of that's you've heard me
talk about my daily gratitude practice
and journaling practice and exercise
practice and taking care of my body
those things practices in and of
themselves i don't think work if they
aren't tethered to somebody who has
a strong sense of
i'm okay with me
and right now you're not okay with you
but i need you to hear me say it's
because you're exhausted because you
can't run all these bricks
if you can set those down
holy smokes
then you walk into the bedroom and
you're like i must be tired anymore you
can go dancing with your friends you're
not so exhausted anymore your head
doesn't hurt your back doesn't hurt
there's remarkable stories there's a
great book by paul conti about trauma
that folks will drop 50 pounds
after
several months of trauma counseling
um
just letting their body process this
stuff and then they're able to move on
and their body quits holding on to
whatever that pathology is
how do i practically start i mean
doing that i guess it's a great question
all right here we go the first thing is
i want you to grab a book
um it's called trauma stewardship
anybody working in
as a trauma nurse should have a copy of
this book when i did a practicum working
with
traumatized and sexually abused kids my
practicum advisor dr gomez gave me this
book and said you cannot work with these
kids until you read this book
i made it to chapter seven and i had to
put it down
and i called him and said i made it to
seven men i'm really struggling with
this book he was hitting home hard and
he laughed and he goes wow man i'm only
to chapter nine right it's a hard book
and it is critical okay
in that book there's several practices i
will give you a few too in fact i want
you to hang on the line um i'm going to
give you a copy of my brand new book on
your past change your future it's
exactly what this is okay okay um it's
not going to come out until april but um
i'm going to put you on the list to give
you a copy of it okay as part of a
pre-order and here's another thing
um it comes with a free month of
counseling from better help okay do you
have a counselor in your area
i i wouldn't know okay
okay we should i mean i just haven't i
guess taking the time to you do i
promise um all of this starts with this
i want you to say these words out loud
i am worth being well
i'm worth being well
if you're not well
your kids can't be
your husband's not gonna be
the people you care for are not gonna be
and when you're a brand new mom of three
bananas beautiful wonderful maniacal fun
kids
and you're also loving and taking care
of people every day and trying to keep a
farm up and
you're proud and you're in love with a
guy who's also keeping his business
running full speed
you go to the bottom of that list
and somehow we picked up this awful
narrative that everybody else needs to
be taken care of before we do
and i need you to begin to say nope i've
got to come first for a season
i've got to make sure
that my oxygen mask is on first before i
try to put it on my kids
what does that practically mean
that means that
you go to bed and you and your husband
work out some sort of schedule with the
kids
that may mean you got to get one of
those little pump machines you may
already have one and husband's got to
wake up a couple nights a week
that may mean that you're going to cut
back on your hours and you are going to
slow down on your wealth building for
the next few years
and create an environment where you can
get some your body can get some rest or
maybe you transfer out of trauma and you
move to another unit
that may mean that you're gonna journal
every day
and you're gonna talk about i miss my
old old eileen
and who is new eileen becoming who is
she gonna be
and you do go to the gym
and you do say
i'm gonna be a good steward of my body
i'm worth feeling good so i'm gonna put
mostly good stuff in my body unless girl
scout cookies are out and let's be
honest then we're all just gonna go
we're gonna crush them right um
i've got a trauma guide
trauma 101 guide you can go to john
delaney.com and go through that
but i want you to begin to
write down on a piece of paper
what does eileen need to be well
what does well mean for me
is it sleep is it connection i'm telling
you right now just listen to your story
you need need to connect with a
counselor
and
i'm going to give you a free month of
counseling with better help that's
that's online counseling if you have a
counselor in your community i'd love for
you to start there as well okay okay
um and this is not
um you sacrificing your kids time your
husband's time this is you being well
and your husband deserves to be well too
um what are you both working so hard for
i
i don't know i i honestly think
it's kind of that idea we have a picture
of what life should look like i came
from a family that was
quite well off he on the other hand did
not
and i think he's trying to
i noticed that like my husband he tends
to give the kids a lot of gifts he
constantly buys them things and we're
financially well off and for me
i guess as a child i grew up having a
lot of things so i just don't care for
them as much as he does he puts a lot of
value on those things so you're running
you're running two something and he's
running away from something
yeah and here's what i want you to do
both of you stop running
stop running
and so you've listened to the show
enough to know that i'm gonna tell you
you all need to get out you've got three
kids clear the deck
great your parents are awesome awesome
that was fun it was fun growing up and
being rich and we had a good time
and his parents didn't have a lot they
loved him clearly he's great at loving
you and those kids awesome
what do we want our one
wild crazy
looney tune reckless filled love life to
look like
just us two and our three little kids
and probably the other nine we're going
to add later on
right i don't know about that what do we
want this is ours it's nobody else's you
all get to paint the picture and this
eileen should be exciting
and fun and oh my gosh let's walk
together towards a thing not run from
something
yeah let's hold hands and walk to a cool
thing we're going to take 50 years to
get there and then we're going to be
we're going to die right we're going to
be dead it's going to be exciting
hopefully i'll make it longer than that
but and and
that's where this thing ends up let's
reverse engineer that what do we need to
do right now you know we need to do
right now i'm going to work less we're
going to make less money i'm going to be
home more i'm going to sleep more i'm
going to be intentional or i'm going to
keep going trauma nurse
and husband
man we're gonna hire somebody for this
farm we're gonna slow things down a
little bit we have to we got to because
we're worth it i'm worth it you're worth
it let's back this thing down a little
bit
and that may not be the solution but
it's an option and when both of you are
running and gunning and flying and going
and going
it just feels like hey this train can't
stop and what i want you to do is it can
it absolutely can
it all starts with you're worth being
well
and now let's reverse engine what does
well mean what does well mean what does
it look like what are the behaviors we
need to do what are the thoughts we have
to do all of it
let's go to john.com check out the
trauma 101 guide we're going to get you
hooked up with this book this book will
walk you through it start to finish i
have a feeling this this book was
written for you eileen it was written
for you
man and let me say i'm so grateful for
you you are awesome great mom great wife
great trauma nurse i know you're
exhausted and you're cooked i know
you're fried and your body has had it
[Applause]
[Music]
it's time for healing we'll be right
back
do you feel like you're always busy
doing something lists chores work stuff
kid stuff pet stuff all of it but you're
never getting anywhere in the areas of
life you really care about like in your
relationships with friends taking care
of your body connecting with your spouse
a romantic partner loving your kids
then it's time to look at the things
you're doing and how your actions are
keeping you from where and who you want
to be
if your actions aren't working for you
anymore that's okay
now is your chance to get up and choose
differently and that doesn't have to be
complicated in fact in my new book own
your past change your future we'll walk
through a common sense approach to
mental health and wellness including
steps to change your actions and move
you closer towards the person you want
to be
if you pre-order today we'll give you
hundreds of dollars of free bonus items
so go to johndaloni.com to start
creating the life you want that's own
your past change your future at
johndaloni.com
hey as we wrap up today's show don't
forget on your past change your future
the new book is
in pre-sale right now
i'm so grateful for everybody for their
support uh please go pick it up get
three month of counseling with
betterhelp.com today's song of the day
john mayer lyrics stop this train
and it goes like this
nope i'm not color blind i know the
world is black and white try to keep an
open mind but i just can't sleep on this
tonight stop this train i want to get
off and go home again
i can't take the speed it's moving in i
know i can't but honestly won't someone
stop this train don't know how else to
say it don't want to see my parents go
one generation's length away from
fighting life out on my own stop this
train i want to get off and i want to go
home again listen everybody you can stop
the train and just go home
you're worth being well we'll see you
soon